you made a video called wind card games
break oh yeah where you got a lot I
can't wait
where a lot of people gave you a lot of
light I got more hate than when I said I
liked the last Jedi you guys I mean I
saw the comments in that video I was
like shocked oh yes quite volatile I
think you made just a technical error on
like one of the I didn't explain it one
of the game mechanics cuz I'm just I'm
dumb I don't I don't know like I'm I
played the game casually and I didn't
understand the mechanics of one of the
things I said that a certain card could
create an infinite loop and the way I
described how that happens is not
exactly how it happens and I I kind of
as my wife told me I I poked the
hornet's nest of the hearthstone gaming
community and boy did they let me know
it it was it was a fun three days of
kind of way over the top it started off
with hey you got this technically wrong
and then it devolved into we're gonna
send death threats to you and your
friends and I still to this day have
people comment on other videos like I
will release a video this Wednesday and
I think guarantee you that there will be
a small section of the comments saying I
just can't listen to anything you say
ever since you messed up that
hearthstone and if that's true then I'm
very sorry that's just it's weird how
fickle kind of well you know people are
very dedicated to their thing that's
their game that's their community and
people will take it as a personal attack
if you say something incorrectly or you
attempt to say something negative about
it and the fact that I had incorrectly
explained a mechanic gave sort of a
scapegoat to write off the actual point
of the video which was the fact that we
now live in a we live in a gaming
environment where games are routinely
patched and altered after
purchased and the whole point of the
video was that you know we we live in
this place where you pay for a certain
product or gaming experience and then
the designer of the game can decide to
alter that experience after you
purchased the game a few years ago if
you went you bought Goldeneye
double-oh-seven for the n64 that was it
that was the game and you knew what
you're paying for and that was the
experience but now you can buy a game
like no man's sky that is a certain type
of game and then a year later it is
completely different sometimes that's a
very good thing in the instance of no
man's sky but in other situations it's
and the whole point was that I started
the video off talking about card games
as a kid that I would play at the middle
school cafeteria i watch middle
schoolers play in the cafeteria and how
the the card game world is shippable I'm
it's regrettable that that legitimate
point was lost in the fact that I I was
just dumb and poorly explained in
mechanic's and it had to devolve into
the to the bashing well I thought was
interesting as it seemed like almost due
to your and this is what I meant by
you'd grown to a big youtuber I think
when you're when you're smaller youtuber
and you make a mistake like that it's
forgivable let you know it's nothing
it's forgivable it's that you can't get
anywhere by calling them out yeah and I
think because you were big at that point
and the video kind of went viral
I saw people making entire videos using
yeah they have my face as the thumbnail
with liar and fraud because I didn't
understand how to play a card game
correctly yeah I don't want to be like
I'm not selling government secrets to
you know a foreign agent or something
I'm just getting a a game mechanic wrong
I'm sorry I'm did like people assign
ill-will to you you don't you don't even
play the game that's all fake footage
that you didn't even record you stole
somebody else's footage and pretended
you don't even play hearthstone couldn't
it just be that I'm just a casual player
and I just did misunderstood the
mechanic and that that's one of the
points of the video is that it's it
causes casual players to want to give up
on the game so I have sorry I don't know
it's like it's why I have like a segue
into my own experience when I was
starting out I like did a kind of
similar thing where I was on the other
side I was like calling out somebody
else
yeah just like philosophy channels okay
and looking back on it did you threaten
to like no no no no but yeah but I think
but I think what happens is when people
see someone successful and if the person
successful makes like a mistake they
assume everything that person is doing
is probably a mistake and they kind of
you know brought these sheeple in into
their you know Locker and it's easy to
kind of pick them out and criticize them
because honestly when you get bigger
you're actually an easier target yeah
who's your target to make fun of because
you have this dedicated fan base and
dedicated fan bases are always easy to
make fun of him so I just thought that
dynamic was interesting of when it
happened to you was very telling like
the kind of attention it was mm-hmm not
that it wasn't right about the specifics
of the game mechanic but the backlash
was so extreme yeah that I think it
maybe showed that there was I think some
people were trying to get some people
not everybody but some people were
trying to get it yeah well I mean when
you create a video that's like got my
face on it with like liar and fraud and
it's like just you know the trash here
you are towards someone the more clicks
you're going to get in some instances
and if people wanted like if people want
to choose that hill to kill me on the
planet you know it's it's whatever they
it's whatever they want to do but the
the great thing about all of this is
that I've tried to be smart and surround
myself with actual friends and family
who are supportive and you know I don't
I don't live and die by weather run name
them video or warriors like me or not I
I get to go home every day and I've got
a wife that loves me and we've got a
wonderful relationship and that's I'm
happy with that I can be content with
that if people want to be mad at me
about misstated because I didn't
understand a card game yeah like leaving
that's awesome and and as I built my
YouTube channel I've looked back that
old video I thought yeah well they
because you become the creator because
I've become the creator with flaws it's
not that my criticisms were were
technically wrong yeah but it's like
it's like you don't give these larger
creators any kind of like well you don't
view them as a person yeah you don't
give them any like like oh they have a
limited budget a limited time to do the
research etc so definitely I kind of
stepped into the shoes a little bit and
realized yeah the kind of pitfalls being
create stuff I mean especially when you
do like educational content or you do
factual content like video essays I get
like three things wrong in every video I
mean if you want a list of the stuff
that I've stated wrong I should even do
a video about all of the factual
inaccuracies you don't have this cuz I'm
just I'm just like I said just subdued
just already making videos I'm gonna
make mistakes I'm going to say something
wrong every now and then and I'm gonna
incorrectly stated a few facts sometimes
it's like because I didn't really
understand it properly sometimes it's
because when I was recording it I said
the wrong number yeah and I didn't catch
it by the time I edited it and sent it
out there because when you're just kind
of DIY anything and you're yourself and
the other thing is sometimes the stuff
that I study or the information that I
look at is actually not accurate or in
the case of certain things it becomes
dated over time and you know it's this
it's one the pitfalls the creator of
being a creator it goes with the
territory you have to learn to not live
and die by whether people are going to
click subscribe or click thumbs up and
if I get something wrong one week you're
just gonna have to you just have to bear
with me forgive me come back next week
and if you decide you don't like it then
stop watching that's fine and you know
all I can do is try and do my best and
it's not gonna be perfect by any means
but it is true that once you become a
creator and once you actually start
having you know once you've got this
you're wearing those shoes then when
people start sending you ridiculously
over-the-top hateful messages and like
literal physical threats you go this
person just doesn't even realize
that they're not viewing you as a human
being at that point like they would
never say those things to me these days
and if they did they would like
immediately know what I'm going to
listen to them but you know that's just
you know that's just the Internet but I
will say that the Internet's been around
long enough now and it's old enough to
where trolls are something you can kind
of write off and it we just don't
[Music]